[Musica]
quando mi hanno
detto che il tema di questa questo the
lack sarebbe stato remare
io ho subito pensato alle montagne cioè
nel senso perché è vero che remare si
accosta sempre al mare a navigare e
tutto quanto però vuol dire anche tanto
sacrificio
uno sfogo con uno sforzo un'azione
andare in una direzione ostinata e
contraria e quindi se penso al
sacrificio
penso alla storia della mia famiglia
principalmente a mio nonno paolo per gli
amici paolino e mio nonno da buon
abruzzese molto testardo e quando si
mette in testa una cosa deve fare per
forza no è sempre andato in una
direzione ostinata e contraria
pensate che a soli sei anni ha contratto
la meningite e il dottore l'aveva dato
per spacciato e così mia nonna la mia
bisnonna anzi rosalinda andò a fare una
devozione a san rocco era il santo
patrono del suo paese e fece questa
devozione e mio nonno guarin
improvvisamente quindi decise anche lui
secondo me che doveva vivere e crebbe
divenne un imprenditore agricolo
però negli anni 60 all'inizio proprio
degli anni 60 gli si presentò questa
occasione ovvero da contadino spostarsi
e andare in vetta sulla maiella prese in
gestione il rifugio pomilio insieme a
sua madre rosalinda iniziarono questa
gestione che si porta avanti fino al
1964 a quell'epoca la montagna era
difficile da raggiungere quel rifugio
era praticamente
seguito solo da da chi andava in
escursione lì è però c'erano degli
escursionisti che appunto si erano
principalmente un escursionista
napoletana che si era affezionata a mia
nonna per il modo che aveva di parlare
con con con le persone di servirle e
iniziò a chiamarla mamma rosa poi nel
punto nel 64 si decise e mio nonno
inizio a decidere di costruire un hotel
qualche chilometro più a valle senza
soldi così semplicemente con dei fondi
personali e tant è che molto spesso
recapitata una volta addirittura che
dovete andare dalla banca perché non
poteva pagare la data della rata del
prestito e gli disse guardi io purtroppo
questo mese non posso pagare e il
direttore della banca e gli disse guarda
lo fanno tutti non me lo vengono mai a
dire siccome si è venuto tu non ti
preoccupare in questo mese è stato
difficile la strada fino al 1964 non ha
rivali e soprattutto la montagna non è
facile sono riusciti a costruire questa
piccola struttura che non è quella che
si può trovare adesso era solo la cucina
e il primo piano ma c'erano qualche
stanza che subito nel 1966 il primo
gennaio 1966 quando aperto non poteva
essere non potevano essere ancora usate
quelle stanze tra loro avevano uno
stanzino accanto alla cucina dove
dormivano sul letto in quattro
mia nonna mio nonno mio padre e suo
fratello e poi andando avanti negli anni
insomma con tanti sacrifici riuscirono
ampliare piano piano la struttura però
appunto la montagna non è non è semplice
faccio degli esempi infatti nel 1968 la
notte di capodanno fece talmente tanta
neve che rimasero bloccati per 40 giorni
dentro la struttura
senza poter mai uscire senza essere
riforniti oppure un altro evento che è
successo appunto nel 1970 e che mio
nonno rimase bloccato con la macchina e
cercò di raggiungere l'hotel e ci riuscì
però rischio l'ipotermia e l'amputazione
di entrambe le gambe
insomma come potete immaginare a ci sono
storie e storie sul mio nonno che potrei
raccontare è però il discorso è perché
vi ho voluto raccontare la storia della
mia famiglia e di mio nonno perché molto
spesso che mi domando il senso del
perché noi siamo su questo pianeta sul
segno che noi vogliamo lasciare tramite
il mio lavoro che è quello di attore
ho la fortuna di poter lasciare impressa
un'immagine di parlare con la mia voce
magari le generazioni future mi potranno
vedere all'opera ancora però il senso
principale secondo me è l'avere un
obiettivo ed ispirare qualcun altro e
mio nonno lo ha fatto il suo unico
obiettivo era quello di dare un futuro
migliore alla sua famiglia e questo
sacrificio
io me lo sono ritrovato geneticamente e
perciò per quanto sia stato difficile
per me lasciare questa terra emigrare a
roma per cercare di diventare attore
io dicevo ma abbiamo hanno affatto 3000
peripezie questa sarà una cosa semplice
per quanto non lo è stata ovviamente
però io se se credo nei miei sogni se
cerco di remare e grazie sicuramente a
mio nonno e all'abruzzo
grazie
[Applauso]